[Musik]
in it geht es um ein rudel kinder lauter
außenseiter kinder ein jüdisches kind
ein kind des stotterns ein kind das zu
buchen da ist weil die mutter irgendwas
anderes irrt hat ein schlüssel mädchen
wo der vater in die zu hause ist und
wenn er zu hause ist das ist ganz übel
also außenseiter geht es die erst von
anderen älteren kids gehänselt und
gepiesackt und unterdrückt und gequält
und gefoltert und ausgebeutet und dumm
angemacht werden und dann auch noch vom
bösen persönlich gejagt wird
[Musik]
das böse sind clown der kommt so alle pi
mal daumen 30 jahre in diese stadt und
das ist eine sehr heimgesuchte stadt und
die rate an kindern wieder verschwinden
oder aufgefressen werden oder
anderweitig zu schaden kommen ist
sechsmal so hoch wie in den restlichen
vereinigten staaten und dieses böse ist
ein clown dass jeweils die gestalt
annehmen kann der sache vor der die
betreffende person die da heimgesucht
wird am meisten angst hat dass der
bonder sieht leprakranken ein anderes
kind sie den werwolf usw
also wir hoffen einfach mal dass angela
merkel diese fähigkeit auch hat
insbesondere im hinblick auf die fdp
geplant ist die verfilmung genauer die
neue verfilmung es gab schon mal eine
frist fernsehen von einem roman von
stephen king eigentlich von den besten
roman von stephen king wobei was dient
auch der beste roman von stephen king
ist und carys der beste roman von
stephen kings 7 gegen hat so viele
bücher geschrieben dass er einfach den
besten roman geschrieben
ein ding etwas böses dass ich kann in
100 von terry an er ist allerbeste an
dem film ist dass er was verstanden hat
was bei king verfilmungen nicht immer
verstanden wird nämlich welche
funktionen eigentlich der schrecken und
das böse bei king hat dass nämlich
einfach ein druckmittel king ist
eigentlich ein lieber kerl er ist auch
ein sehr liberaler mensch der sich im
grunde wünscht dass die leute alle diese
sozialen übel die es so gibt ausschluss
einsperren unterdrücken ausbeuten usw
überwinden können durch solidarität und
zusammenleben und sie müssen einfach ein
bisschen gejagt und ermordet werden um
das zu lernen wie das geht und diese
kinder lernen dass in dem film
schauspielerin die die berger lima
spielt die sophia nilles ist die ideale
besetzung um das ganze ding so
zusammenzuhalten
der chairman tel ein anderes kind spiels
etwas übergewichtigen der er ein haiku
schreibt ein liebesgedicht das so die
seele von diesen ganzen dingen ist und
der trick ist einfach diese kinder die
haben sich gern sind aber auch rivalen
es gibt ein verlust geschichten usw und
die ganze aufgabe besteht darin sich
nicht auseinander treiben zu lassen von
diesem fiesen clown und ihm einfach was
entgegenzusetzen ja ich habe nachgesehen
seht ihr an es ist durch die
kanalisation verbunden da unten lebt
heißt der film ist von andy massierte
wenn man ihn so ausspricht ein
argentinier der einen sehr guten film
namens mama mit zwei mädels aus dem wald
gedreht hat und jetzt einen noch
besseren film gedreht hat nämlich diese
der film hervorragend geeignet für
kinder natürlich insbesondere wenn sie
ein herzschrittmacher haben und für
ältere leute nicht so weil man kann
schon ein bisschen angst
[Applaus]
[Musik]